so this week I've got a whole bunch of
objectives the most important of which
is get some computer code running I also
need to write at least a couple more
pages of my theory chapter of my thesis
which I've been sort of slowly writing a
over the past couple of weeks and months
I have meeting with supervisors later on
this week which I want to have some
stuff for and hopefully be able to
present the plan for how I'm going to
complete my thesis and then on top of
all the PhD stuff I've also got to write
a talk to keep in London and I've also
got a whole bunch of singing stuff to do
which you'll sit back less desk
so this morning I had several hours I've
allocated for non PhD things so I run an
Access Project an Oxford cookie oxblood
project which is getting students to
blog about their daily life and we have
huge document which is all about like
basically the charter project so I was
updating that for a long time this
morning and then doing other things like
life admin sorting out emails just
things that I'm going to think about if
I'm not actually working now I've
actually got to work
so I probably experiment my PhD is
actually about the brief version is that
you can divide the atmosphere up to
different layers and we live in a layer
called troposphere which at the bottom
of this layer there above that's called
stratosphere and in the stratosphere in
the stratosphere you see these really
big events called sudden stratospheric
warming which are basically most violent
things that happen in the Earth's
atmosphere we know that these things
have an effect on the surface weather
we just don't quite know why they do how
they do my thesis is essentially testing
one hypothesis we have about how that
happens and I came home by the way
because my camera died also so I do me
editing on my big computer here which
broke and I've just sent it away to be
fixed and this is the moment of truth
see if it works or not now
it would help if I turn the power on
oh I work I am so happy to see that
light again this is Dan we're off to do
some singing we're so we're both members
of the Chapel Choir
we are indeed and every Monday well this
is the last one actually for the time
being
we've been doing these little gigs in a
tiny little church just on Cathedral
green on where we were singing yesterday
at the Cathedral and it's just a whole
bunch of music in extra second oldest
church second oldest yeah because as we
hear every week in the history talk this
just celebrated a nine hundred fiftieth
anniversary it was founded in 1065 yeah
right yeah
by the first Bishop of Exeter it's a
nice little church hey my be amazing
yeah
here's the music
so this week's kind of been a weird one
that's not the line I was going to say
CSI left my camera ran out of battery
the other thing that I wanted to talk
about yesterday that I didn't get a
chance to because the camera dying was
the fact that doing a PhD is kind of
weird like it's not like every other
stage in your education where the
answers are definitely known which is a
problem because the work that I'm doing
at the moment I am doing something and
then I have to check if it's right and
sort of compare it to a bunch of other
stuff in the field but there's no
guarantee that that stuff is right and
equally there's no guarantee that the
method I'm using to see if it's right is
right there's any number of ways in
which I can be wrong and I milder I'll
probably all of them good morning and
you gorgeous I've made a friend
since following me
you you can't slap
oh hey it's me little things
campus is busy today
you
I was pretty much in mourning actually
so I've got the point now where with my
work it's been this countable
malfunctioning so long but I'm kind of
just trying everything like looking at
every stage look at every variable that
music and just sort weaking it
multiplying it by thousand dividing it
by a thousand seeing what makes a
difference and at some point I'm gonna
climb with promise
laughter I probably had a full day
whenever done today like the vast
majority of the day was spent still
trying to get this code to work and
whilst I didn't get it working I've now
got some better ideas about sort of how
it's not working if that makes sense
the other thing which I did was write
some code which is going to use the code
that isn't working when it works to do a
whole bunch of different calculations so
it's like the master program what I've
been working on is effectively like
building a specialized tool and this
next bit of code is actually using that
tool and turn clues on how to use it so
that's nearly well I started it let's
put a lever now though I'm going off
into uni because I want to sign for
Amazon and let's pick up Locker here I'm
really quite excited
much question it was earlier Ivan who's
this we got we've got quite another
quite member Jacob is a he or fester
right I'm person and you are studying
history and I owe I owe international
relations all right I'll see you
tomorrow yeah yes okay nice guy one
thing that's definitely worth noting
about expert is it's really bloody hilly
so this is the ski slope you have to
kind of go up and down whenever you go
to campus this needs to go somewhere
yeah
so unfortunately my housemaid Dan has
gone upstairs because he's not feeling
terribly well so I'm going to cut
filming for tonight what I am going to
be doing is doing some editing for Vera
CG projects and doing some writing for
this talk that I need to be giving next
month basically that's what I'm up to
but I'll see you guys so this morning's
been a pretty standard kind of set I've
just been sat coding entire mornings
basically Caroline was doing yesterday
afternoon just quite nice my hair
sticking up but I thought I'd come out
here to show you this view this is the
view from the top of my building the
thing about Exeter is close to these
backs to you it's the city on there it's
that uni on the hill so get that view
right the way down to the sea you can
just about see over there and it's also
I think it's got the highest tree to
student ratio of any Union in the
country but it needs to be an arboretum
so the view from here is most to green
which is very nice in fact the Exeter
sort of hashtag is hashtag bleep green
so seeing as it's been quite a morning I
thought I explained a little bit more
about exactly what I'm coding on what
the problem codes been so basically what
I've been working on this equation where
you have some variable Q that you know
and you know the Q is equal to L acting
on side the Greek letter
l here is just some linear operator it's
a bunch of functions like adding bits of
site together or differentiating it or
what happened now the problem is you
know what Q is you're working out what
retires and the way you do that is
through well I'm using a method called
successive over relaxation E which
basically means that you're using this
equation which is actually much simpler
than it looks effectively what you're
doing is you you're guessing what the
answer is and then you're correcting
that guess and seeing how much you're
increasing or how much are changing your
guess every time and the computer code
I'm working on is basically doing this
and then it terminates after a certain
you know I've just an accuracy after the
correction gets small enough now the
problem I've been having is that until
recently it wasn't converging so the
corrections were getting bigger and
bigger every time until you just have to
pull the plug recently I've changed that
I fixed it I found what was just a
really small problem as an indented
block in my code and now it converges
but it converges to the right answer and
it's given me temperatures that make no
sense like negative Kelvin temperatures
so I'm what I've been Kari trying to do
it make sense of that and fix it and
make converge to the right thing but
it's it's still not and it's getting a
bit frustrating because I need to get
this done in order to get my PhD
finished but um it's not playing ball
and I've been working on this for I
think it has been a couple of months now
just sort of trying to get this working
and this this is the the crucial tool
there's the very finally constructor
tool that I need to use in order to get
my PhD done and all the other stuff that
I do depends on this video
and it's frustrating because this isn't
actually going to appear in my thesis
this enables me to flip it into my
thesis given that I'm in my last year
and I need to I definitely pressure to
get stuff done it's not the best when
you feel like you know you come against
a roadblock and you nobody knows why
it's going wrong but the thing is if I
don't do it nobody's going to do it for
me so I need to keep trying I'm taking a
couple of hours off at the moment sort
of working on what I'm going to be doing
after this I know it works but
eventually I'm going to have to fix it I
will just turn over when or how
okay so it's not a bit later and making
some interesting progress I went back to
the misbehaving code I feel like I've
identified what the problem is it's to
do with ham looking at things changing
in the vertical like I've pinpointed
down exactly what we're going wrong now
just got to fix it which I'm gonna do
I'm going to go back to the office after
I'm done with singing which is where I'm
going now yeah so I've not got to get
dressed
with this Sophie she's one of us upon us
he's also a cheerleader which is just
like this you've got vast you Italian
yes bossy
button struggles up
so that was evensong this is something
if you want to know more about me singer
there's a link up there and down in the
description I did a whole video about
doing choir stuff basically I sing in
University of Exeter Chapel Choir we
sing and even song every Wednesday we
wear the fancy green Kasich's then we
have the surpluses on top for the actual
service for stuff in the service a shot
like Dan because he's not feeling
terribly well so he wasn't singing today
normally he'd be on tenor we didn't
actually have an organist today which is
unusual for us normally we have an
accompanying was under companies
including a piece which we hadn't seen
before today now I'm just gonna quickly
head back to the office because I've
been thinking about the problem that my
code was having what's a squirrel its
collar so that I may talk squirrel
Exodus campus is ridiculous flawed life
if you've got like squirrels rabbits
foxes badges
anyway I'm now going back to the office
to a bit of work because I've been
thinking about what the problems are
plaguing me and I think I've isolated
exactly what it is but I'm no idea why
it's not working so just a little bit of
time then I'm gonna go home
well this is getting more and more
frustrating this feels like oh man like
the mall that I I double this this
program the less I seem to understand
how to fix this I will but now I need to
get home I need to get some edits on the
go rendering I need to eat and watch
bake-off so there's yet another morning
of coding this was continuing to from
the problems but nothing for the cones
of plowing on under the assumption I
will eventually solve the problem code
and also doing a lot of stuff right in
my hands so this week I've been trying
to set myself a sort of time length when
I'm going to be getting each part my
thesis done so thesis is the thing that
lets you clear self a doctor the end of
the day you do your research and you
write it up with a document called a
thesis which at least in this field is
150 200 pages long it's your original
research it's a summary of the field and
interested outlines what you've
contributed then you submit that thesis
and then you sit what's called a fiver
which is anything from you know two
hours to a full day of discussing your
research with a lot expert in your very
specific field a lot of people don't
it's not really an exam it's a defense
of what you've done which means it's
really just the chance to have really
interesting conversation that somebody
is very good at what you know you've
done so I just wolf down some lunch at
my desk because I am now going to do
what I've been trying to do every
lunchtime this week I've actually been
pretty bad at it and that's going to do
some scene practice so the University of
Exeter doesn't actually have a music
department so all the people that you
actually have busy with yesterday and
the chapel choir
don't do music Whitney but we do have
the largest extracurricular music
program of any university in the UK so
there's this huge building here this is
Cottle house which is full of practice
rooms and ensemble rooms where anybody
can who has a music card which is very
cheap to get can just book in through as
long as they like to rehearse on one of
these these pianos so I'm gonna be
working through some stuff for the
Chapel Choir and also for some
material which isn't going to be brought
any relevance for a couple of weeks yet
I just like to point out the ridiculous
quantity of music this is this isn't
even everything for the term I mean this
is this is even touching the Christmas
or the remember it stuff it doesn't even
fit in our folders anymore this is
ridiculous
okay so I think I might have
identifiable problems with the code
something like a very minor point it
says pay to find vertical derivatives
well it's not interested but I've just
wolf down a pub dinner because there's a
campus pub which is just behind me there
this is the dream I'm not going to go up
too quiet and I need a huge magic
because I'm like right about time now is
this yet more music hello peace die no
no no no never has the music in
rehearsal made me angrier
well that was a dire rehearsal of music
spared by the Holst which is now sleek
Bangor
ah live lives here but she just want to
appear on camera enough we're now going
to watch the game of Thrones and then
get a night because I want to get up on
campus early see if we can follow up on
this idea and fix the code once and for
all which is really really exciting okay
so it's currently 7:00 a.m. I just half
an hour ago caught myself and very
disgruntled girlfriend out of bed I'm
sorry and we're going to try make the
most of I think is finance relation to
escaping problems I think I'd like to
point out the live I've created being in
a clip but demanded two takes because
her hair looked too scruffy from the
back okay so I know definitely the
pressure to have dropped live off so
actually get some work done otherwise I
got a rougher laugh by six for nothing
okay so here's the situation
um I just went through and basically
kind of stripped out when you're looking
at this program you're looking at how
this this parable berries in three
dimensions your up-down left-right back
forward so I just stripped out the
up-down because that was the problem
dimension and I retweet everything about
this nine route a term that I think
should have been there in the first
place this now works fine like it's it's
perfect if you weren't even interested
in looking at two dimensions now I'm
adding in the third dimension which
fingers crossed it's gonna work this
let's see
so this is the problem that we're having
this is the field that I'm generating
the stream function the the colors and
then the arrows are the velocities that
you can get from that and everything's
pretty close so this is what we expect
to see this is what I'm calculating
everything's pretty good apart from this
the pole and the temperature field that
results from that is I don't know if you
can see this is really wrong the
velocity is looking pretty good
apart from here nearly crack-tip we have
replaced one problem with another but at
least now we are much much closer to the
truth that you kind of see in the
atmosphere time to get lunch and be
quick about it because we're really
pumped to try and finish this know
you've divided your enemies which makes
it easier to conquer them okay well I
feel like a monk because I just got a
pie for lunch and there was this farmers
market here which is here I think every
Friday now in term time
a poor decision it's really good to got
loads of local foods and then like
international foods as well this house
is amazing
Matt's from something is veggie
well that's bloody annoying isn't it
this definitely feels like I'm going mad
like it's it's almost sadistic at this
point it gives me hope and it takes it
away but still I feel like I have to
respond to these things in a mature
manner so I made use of the time and I
set up another program which is running
over the weekend hopefully I'll be
finished by the time we get in on Monday
I think the preliminary results telling
me that what we assumed there was going
to be difference between these two
methods and it looks like there's not
which is kind of going against what
other research papers have found well at
least one paper off top of my head
that's something I have more data to
make sense of on Monday now I'm going
home
hey hey - I guess in Jena yeah yes
sometimes the leaves I mean on the
Riviera
that was me after choir today I like to
try and play tennis
at least occasionally to turn well I'd
start doing sports if you sort of
stopped as well and you yeah yeah so
it's not--it's nice even if it's just
two people and we are going to try and
do doubles yeah our level of skill was
definitely trouble enough to ever try to
find him that was family won't be
embarrassed by a level kind of poor poor
Ken we did legit just choose that tennis
golf because it was as far away from
everybody responsible including the kids
class don't get because I girl have been
a lesson right now really well I was
learning getting free advice oh and look
what we have here we've spotted a
woodland sprite look at him go going
about his business
oh I think he's found some nuts
well this doesn't look good
this is so what I don't need right now
at least my room's tidy so we're just
out shopping I have now got a new jacket
because I needed a coke it's now winter
and we're now trying to find live
something that's going to keep her warm
because she's complaining incessantly
about the keys the whole the cold the
cold she was in Spain last year in a
depends looking River Island and try not
to show your face well the English
summer's over to fair the English summer
also not like this oh my god you're
gonna look like my that's literally the
same texture as my teddy bear but I
definitely used to have you've become
like the Yeti on my youtube channel
alright no one's ever gonna see you
we managed it and the Sun came out okay
it's Sunday morning on computers still
not working so I can't do anything
actually useful
so Liv and I are going to go into town
we're picking up some stuff to make a
veggie Sunday roast
so there's actually quite an interesting
day because we've got this then this
evening I've got a live stream and then
after that we've got a party to go to
when we're going to do some funds under
activities I didn't think we were doing
maths questions on the TV my cha look at
that pie shot
it's the tastiest of all charts supply
chart
are you enjoying this done [ __ ]
loving at night
I love maths maybe that's right I got it
wrong well I'm studying English and
classics okay
right this is the live stream that's
about to happen now because of the
problems that we had at home I'm doing
in the office so this is where I'm back
at 6:30 on a on a Sunday evening Oh
white top and white background that's
not a good idea
but yeah I'm about the live stream with
Thomas Frank and Jamie miles there's a
link that's already happened so there's
a link down there in the description to
this event if you want to watch it were
answering questions about uni and
revision and studying and I'm late so I
should join Paul assistant stuff and
then I had a tough time accepting this
but I started come a little bit burned
out with and I was the live stream done
that was a lot of fun I always love
doing these live streams we might be
doing the more regularly from now as
well that's just another thing to start
thinking about do you think I'm taking
on too much like I've got too many
things on my plate maybe I should just
focus on trying to get this PhD done
so the cool thing about this party is it
means I get to go back in time a few
hundred years because my house is had an
hour I'll just say the front door so
this is the front door out that was me
hitting my head
he's very overweight but we love looks
like